Hey guys, why am I excited about tribe of
mentors? What makes it different? Well,
this is a cookbook and encyclopedia of
tactics that are immediately actionable
tools that are immediately actionable.
So you have probably 20 plus billionaires,
20 plus worldclass athletes,
every possible area you can imagine people
talking to what they do when they get
overwhelmed,
this specific self talk and actions they
take when they're trying to say decline
something,
say no.
So they don't get over committed
how they exercise in the mornings,
how they work out on the road,
how they've planned for breaking
records for 10 x 100 x thing results.
So with any flip of any page,
you should be able to find
something that'll change
your life and do so quickly.
So good luck and enjoy.
Hey guys,
if you're enjoying the tips and tactics
and how to on this channel or in the
podcast, the Tim Ferriss show, I
made this for you, tribe of mentors,
short advice from the best in the world.
This is the book that I wanted to read.
So I went out and I put it together,
created a dream list of 130
of the best at what they do.
People who are icons, legends, and
ask them all the same questions.
These are people in some cases
I wanted to reach out to.
My whole life ranges from many,
many billionaires,
cofounders of every company imaginable,
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis to power lifting. Everything else,
country stars, actors, directors,
and you can spot the patterns.
So some of my friends have said
this is the easiest to read,
most useful book that
I've put together yet.
So checking out tribe of mentors.com
you can find sample chapters,
the whole list of mentors,
everything. Tribe of mentors.com.